welcome to this video I'm playing fritz
kya from the US five wins two losses is
my score let's see what happens and then
playing 1.e4 and need some some change
of pace em let's see what happens I
think p3 right Wow relieved that the
displayable queen age five here nothing
okay maybe some normal moves should
suffice for form a decent position doing
anything fancy him yeah the bird
variation of the Spanish I have played
that in blitz once in a while without
any great knowledge this is the problem
very often with those sidelines they
tend to your very often they're not that
bad but they require specific knowledge
to even stay on the board with some some
second rate moves you're very often just
wiped out without ever getting into the
game okay trying to put some pressure on
the d4 pawn maybe black should just
place you five camera this
Bishop f6 is probably also not bad
take someone here that's something
special possible him that I'm not seeing
IC 5 some of those moves are not working
maybe I don't see however how c5 should
be playable
hmm I don't know yeah then at the end he
is still playing it k Bishop t2 was
nothing special but I'm still one minute
behind where did aspect of this time
it's really sick em okay 95 to our
Bishop g5 actually maybe Bishop g5
getting rid of this piece I have six
maybe night coming to G fire can go to
you form this this kind of stuff should
be five maybe I can also take here and
play age three
it's both good 55 quindi five Bishop f6
now that looks good but complicated
I wanted to go G for him we see
sacrificing I cannot believe it really
but might might I it's not working let's
not work I've changed to all the time
okay now 95 this was the point gaining
the space and getting this pressure on
f7 I can I can maybe even continue with
their form it's not necessary but it can
be an option just taking on g6 and queen
of three years not bad as well
I phim now F for this maybe 95 being a
problem
yeah so keep it keep it simple I can
take only one ok this would have helped
him rook takes you one the intermedia
check now I have g5 and now and I'm also
attacking num b7
okay I still have this pressure should I
play rookie for may be initiating a
doubling of rooks yeah I guess if he
takes Queen takes i still keep control
over the evil one minute 30
camera next move will be rookie one
basically no matter what I keep control
over the e-file that's very nice
25 is a simple solution not sure if it's
the best solution but it's simple so
just leading to a very nice position for
wide okay so counterplay here intending
also Rugare form
yeah if seven is just tough too tough to
hold right so it's a very clear
demonstration of high morning or should
begin snow TM this some direct way no I
guess I take the pawn
I just get the default pawn then two
pawns up and it's not yet he does not
play with the king check our that's a
stalemate I'm not believing this I'm
running into a stalemate Rick the only
way not to judge him unbelie-- Jung
check some way to avoid yet check ah
really no no no no check check check
general way to avoid a tree limb check
stalemate I cannot believe it how it got
it can you beam after this demonstration
yeah from totally out playing that the
the person from one yet never ever a
single thread in the game and then I run
into this bloody stalemate Rick check I
simply forgot about it and I can do this
all the time actually it's not really a
matter of putting the pawn over there
it's just just yeah I wasn't around and
I simply forgot that it exists yeah it's
it's just two points for 4 zip and pip
can win it well however I want him whoo
thanks for watching